huge story right now and good news is
it's been remedied but all this morning
flights to Kevin going in and out of the
state's grounded because of a computer
outage yeah almost 4 000 because of this
uh computer outage now the White House
is saying that this is not because I
think a lot of us think here in 2023
when we hear about a massive computer
outage that this is some sort of cyber
terrorism maybe that's happened or
occurred but the White House says that's
not the case but yeah the good news is
flights have resumed but you can expect
if you do have a flight today
particularly here in Canada because this
affects worldwide right because there's
flights coming into places like
Vancouver airport Toronto Pearson
Airport as well this has got some real
implications for travelers all over the
world so even though things are back up
and running this morning uh you can
expect I'm sure delays throughout the
day as they play catch-up yeah
we don't know what the cause of it is
they're expecting the table within a
couple hours they
[Music]
don't know okay